Salut ! Nous sommes en plein cœur des énigmes de l'été.
Cette petite série que j'ai créée. Une énigme par jour pendant 32 jours à l'intérieur du défi du Mental Vlog.
Avant de vous donner l'énigme d'aujourd'hui, la réponse à lénigme d'hier.
Comme d'habitude, si vous n'avez pas vu l'énigme d'hier, regardez la avant, parce que là je donne la réponse.
Ca tient grâce à deux choses assez subtiles mais pourtant réelles.
JS est né le 31 décembre. Donc c'est vrai, mon pote JS est né le 31 décembre.
Et au moment où on formule l'énigme, on est le 1er janvier.
Donc le 1er janvier, il a 18 ans.
Avant hier, il avait bien 17 ans, puisqu'on était le 30 décembre.
Cette année en cours, l'année dont on parle, l'année du 1er janvier, il aura donc 19 ans à la fin de l'année.
Et donc l'année prochaine, il aura bien 20 ans.
C'est pour ça que ça fonctionne.
C'est tout a fait possible qu'avant hier il ait eu 17 ans, et que l'année prochaine il ait 20 ans.
Peut-être que vous trouvez ça tordu. Aujourd'hui vous allez voir c'est beaucoup moins tordu je pense.
Enigme 19, énigme mathématique.
Ca fait un petit moment que je ne vous ai pas fait de maths, comme ça dans les énigmes.
Alors ça se trouve, il n'y a pas de calculs compliqués, c'est plutôt le raisonnement et la logique qui faut avoir.
Si 800 poules pondent 800 œufs en 8 jours, combien d'œufs sont pondus par 400 poules en 4 jours ?
Je répète, si 800 poules pondent 800 œufs en 8 jours, combien d'œufs pondent 400 poules en 4 jours ?
Et la réponse est simple, c'est...
demain, que je vous la donnerai, comme tous les jours !
Oui, évidemment !
Dès que vous trouvez la réponse, faites le moi savoir en laissant un pouce en l'air, que je voie le nombre de personnes qui ont trouvé la réponse à cette énigme.
Profitez du soleil, de la plage, de tout ce que vous voulez !
En tout cas passez un bel été.
Bon courage peut-être à ceux qui bossent en ce moment.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner  avant de partir, voir même de partager une énigme de temps en temps sur votre page Facebook
par exemple !
Parce que le Mental Vlog, c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17H !
Ciao !